les Allemands n'avaient visiblement pas
l'esprit à la fête hier soir les
cérémonies de célébration du 10e
anniversaire de la chute du Mur n'ont
guerre rassemblé plus de 30000 personnes
et ce n'est pas seulement la pluie qui
explique ce manque d'enthousiasme
correspondance à Berlin d'Olivier
Lerner on attendait au moins 100000
personnes pour fêter l'événement mais la
pluie le froid la morosité générale
surtout on réduit la foule à sa portion
conrue00 personnes plus pour ce qui
devait être la nuit la plus longue la
plus joyeuse la plus fraternelle depuis
1989 sur plusieurs kilomètres on pouvait
suivre l'ancien tracé du mur une
promenade à travers le temps révolue
aujourd'hui l'Allemagne de l'Ouest
investit à l'Est 450 milliards de francs
par an et tout citoyen est mis à
[Musique]
contribution le mur existe toujours dans
les têtes et ça va durer encore la façon
de vivre à l'Est et à l'Ouest était
tellement différ
oui moi je crois qu'il faudra attendre
la génération suivante pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de différence entre nous ce
fossé c'est normal s'il existe encore
aujourd'hui ça ne va pas si mal je ne
suis pas trop pessimiste ils étaient
tous là les acteurs stressé de 89
spectateur libérés
aujourd'hui même si le mur de béton a
été détruit parfois le mur est dans les
têtes ici en Allemagne et je dirais un
peu partout dans le monde le mur de
l'argent le mur sociale le mur du
racisme le mur de la pauvreté il y a
encore beaucoup de murs à abattre pe
partout dans le
monde avec sa baguette magique
rostropovic a enflammé Berlin l'espace
d'une nuit blanche le mur aujourd'hui
n'est plus qu'un décor froid une ligne
de partage qui aura servi de cadre
pendant 28 ans dans cette ville où l'on
n pas prêt d'oublier ses images gravé
dans la pierre et dans les
têtesend000 personne pour fêter
l'événement mais la pluie le froid la
morosité générale surtout ont réduit la
foule à sa portion
congrue 30000 personnes pas plus pour ce
qui devait être la nuit la plus longue
la plus joyeuse la plus fraternelle
depuis
1989 sur plusieurs kilomètres on pouvait
suivre l'ancien tracé du mur une
promenade à travers le temps révolue
aujourd'hui l'Allemagne de l'Ouest
investit à l'Est 450 milliards de francs
par an et tout citoyen est mis
[Musique]
contbution le mur existe toujours dans
les têtes et ça va durer encore la façon
de vivre à l'Est et à l'Ouest était
tellement différente
ou moi je crois qu'il faudra attendre la
génération suivante pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de différence entre nous ce fossé
c'est normal s'il existe encore
aujourd'hui ça ne va pas si mal je ne
suis pas trop pessimiste ils étai tous
là les acteurs stressés de 89
spectateurs libérés aujourd'hui
même si le mur de béton a été détruit
parfois le mur est dans les têtes ici en
Allemagne et je dirais un peu partout
dans le monde le mur de l'argent le mur
des exclusions sociales le mur du
racisme le mur de la pauvreté il y a
encore beaucoup de murs à abattre à peu
partout dans le monde avec sa baguette
magique rostropovic a enflammé Berlin
l'espace d'une nuit blanche le mur
aujourd'hui n'est plus qu'un décor froid
une ligne de partage qui aura servi de
cadre pendant 28 ans dans cette ville où
l'on n'est pas prêt d'oublier ces images
gravées dans la pierre et dans les
têtes